ladies and gentlemen Academy Award
winner of Frances McDormand
[Applause]
okay guys sit up straight and a
presentable the five distinguished
nominees for Best Actor in a leading
role are Matt Damon in Good Will Hunting
[Applause]
Robert Duvall in the Apostle
Peter Fonda and ulee's gold
[Applause]
Dustin Hoffman in wag the dog
[Applause]
Jack Nicholson in as good as it gets
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to Jack Nicholson is
good
[Applause]
Nicholson has been nominated for 11
Academy Award this is his third win he
previously took home Oscars for his
performances in One Flew Over the
[Applause]
very much the members of the Academy for
this and I the other nominees some of
them are very good friends of mine and
I'm honored to be on any list with you
Bobby
dusty and you and your father mr. Damon
and my old bike pal Fonda we're very
proud of the picture we had like I don't
know I've had a sinking feeling all
night right up till here something about
it we had Jim Brooks Maria Cavanaugh
Christie Zia Brigitte Johnson Peter and
Rose Laura Ziskin so many producers on
the picture I can't remember them all
mr. Andros and mr. Brooks wrote the
script cast mist hunt mr. Kinnear
Cuba Gooding Skeet Ulrich Shirley Knight
I know Gil Cates is starting to sweat
back there now as new villain Suzy go
ahead with it all right
sure
[Applause]
and I'd like to think I'd like to thank
everybody here tonight for looking so
good I'd like to dedicate this to Miles
Davis Robert Mitchum
shorty Smith Joe Vautrin or8 Cramer
Rupert cross JT Walsh and wanna Anders
they're not here anymore but they're in
my heart I thank you very much
[Applause]